buen dia liliana efectivamente esta esta
decisión mayoritaria expresada en
presentó el día de ayer que significa
que la ciudadanía ha ordenado de forma
contundente hoy día el estado de américa
y tiene el poder de términos políticos y
económicos debe dar respuesta adecuada a
esta demanda ciudadana en términos de
una convención participativa como nunca
antes había hecho en chile en segundo
lugar ha asociado a una idea de
desarrollo que implique los derechos y
la dignidad humana y la calidad de vida
asegurada mediante la constitución pero
también con la posibilidad de poder
generar una hoja de ruta que lleve al
país por la paz por la concordia pero
con ideas claras en largo plazo de tal
forma de que la luz acción del poder
siempre esté a visible para el ciudadano
y no se sienta ni amenazado por el
mercado ni abandonado por el estado
bueno pero ayer vimos también además de
la asistencia de la sur las nuevas
concentraciones y un ambiente festivo al
anunciarse que había ganado en apruebo
cómo queda la temperatura social en el
país después del plebiscito y cuáles son
los principales retos para esta nueva
etapa que empieza en chile
de hecho en el día de ayer los
incidentes de violencia fueron mínimos
con lo cual la idea de que existe un
consenso en torno al sistema político
debe introducir cambios estructurales
importantes que benefician la sociedad
quedó claramente estampada los desafíos
hoy día comienzan con una negociación
técnico política que tiene que ver
respecto a cuál cerró dos independientes
en el proceso electoral para elegir a lo
que a los constituyentes qué cosa va a
pasar con los pueblos originarios en
términos de cuotas para que también
participen en todo ello y
específicamente dejar de lado en una
suerte de distribución de poderes
concentrados solamente a los partidos
políticos el gran desafío del día
entonces es una negociación que sea
inclusiva que sea como coherente con lo
que la ciudadanía quiere donde el poder
los partidos políticos deberán con la
manera de abrirse también a una mayor
incorporación de ciudadanos que no estén
vinculados los partidos políticos y es
una propuesta además que no posee la
citología de izquierdo a derecho
proveniente del siglo 20 sino que está
muy enmarcada dentro
desafíos y esperanzas del siglo 21 pues
agradecemos ese análisis con guillermo
holzmann analista y consultor político
desde viña del mar en chile